[Music]
William King Hale this is an
extraordinary character who says you
know these most beautiful people on
God's Earth he was respectful on the one
hand
and murderous Thug on the other hand
you're gonna make trouble make it big
William K Hale wanted to take control of
Osage wealth and territory at all costs
that state money flows the right
direction it'll come to us was
exploiting and manipulating them
and if necessary do away with them
almost as if it was for their own good
gonna kill this Envy how'd you know
[Applause]
in real life William Hale was the
banality of evil so many troubles will
be brought upon you Robert De Niro is
one of the people on this planet that
can change the temperature in a room he
is so powerful they're gonna go
their time is over
will happen